all right Sarah Sarah where are you from
originally where'd you grow up
um Orange County
yeah tell me about your family
um my mom and my dad were married they
had um three kids
um I have two older brothers
and
um my mom died when I was five
I could lose your mom
um
on Thanksgiving uh my mom my right
before my mom passed away she separated
with my dad
so her and her boyfriend uh had me in
the car and we were going to my
grandma's for Thanksgiving my dad and my
brothers went in another car
and um like a share it was like a
sheriff's wife she had ran a red light
and
um hit us and the car like flipped over
um her boyfriend had like a broken
collar bone
um and then she passed away
um and then I I was fine like I was I
guess I was just like throwing up a lot
all night from like shock or something
but
but yeah like
um so like I haven't had a mom like
pretty much my whole life so like it
doesn't really like
I feel like kind of like sometimes I
don't know what it's like to have
a mom like I have two kids actually
um sometimes I feel like that's part of
why like
I've had such a struggle with like
motherhood like my one child is with his
father and my other child was taken away
um
do some things but yeah so
um anyways but um yeah so my dad raised
us we live pretty well like we lived in
Mission Viejo
um like he guessed I showed us love like
financially like we had a lot of
we we were comfortable you know like
middle class I guess
and um my older brother like uh he had
found out that
so my dad and mom had met when
um
they knew each other in the office and
she was pregnant she with another man
and had the baby and and he left when
when my brothers four days old
um
he said I can't do this and walked out
the door
well so my mom and dad started dating
when my brother was basically just like
an infant so he's been my brother's dad
his whole life you know but they never
um like went through and actually like
did the paperwork to adopt him
so when my mom died when my brother was
like 13.
he had to deal with like finding out his
mother died and finding out that his
father who he thought was his father
wasn't his father and his real father
was a drug addict and he didn't give a
[ __ ] the day he was supposed to show up
to tell him he was his father didn't
even show up
because my dad was like I'm not gonna do
it I'm not gonna I'm not gonna like do
that for you you know
so anyway so he started struggling with
drugs and like my dad pretty much did
everything possible she had to help him
but my brother just kept stealing from
him like
you know kept like doing drought we
could there's paraphernalia everywhere
in the house like he just was focusing
so much on trying to help Chris
like his friends and family were like
you have two other kids you like need to
take care of you know
and so I just grew up kind of seeing
that like finding spoons and like
the little heroin balloons and like I
remember like coming home from vacation
once and being like Daddy Daddy like
Chris threw a party like there's
balloons you know and my dad was just
like oh my God like give me that you
know
so he got out of the house
and up later on that me and my brother
would end up like using drugs together
as like a way to like Bond
um
but um yeah like so so then I started
acting out
um I think because of that my dad was he
was depressed you know my dad's gay
yeah super weird I found out when I was
like 18 18 my dad like was gay and like
my whole life I thought like yeah he
kept that promise anyways but and he has
HIV and I found that out when I was
young there's just been like a lot of
secrets in my family like um there's a
lot of things that have like come to
light like my uncle like committed
suicide he hung himself and we are lied
to our whole lives and told like that he
like choked on like throw up on his
sleep like there's just been like all
these family secrets and just as I was
getting older I was just kind of like
you know like you're not supposed to lie
to your children like I know a lot of it
was to protect us but it just felt like
really confusing
and so
um
um like I had a friend's mom she tried
to adopt me because she didn't feel like
my dad was like taking like care of us
you know
um
and so I went to go live with them like
nothing was done in the court but just
whatever
and uh she had an older brother I didn't
know he was a drug addict or addicted to
like heroin
supposedly he was clean but I didn't
know but he's 22 and I was 15.
and I went upstairs like
and uh he was there and we were watching
TV and he's like oh do you want to smoke
and at the time I was smoking weed I was
like a Little Pothead and so
um I thought he meant weed so I went
upstairs like yeah sure and I saw the
foil and
you know I knew just from like my
brother what it was like that it was
heroin and I was always so against it
like I was like I'm never gonna do that
like I'm never gonna use heroin it's so
horrible they're just so pathetic
looking back that it's like
I literally like everything that's led
me up to my life at this point
was like peer pressure of not wanting to
look stupid like
like you know it's like I'm homeless on
the streets now
I've lost everything lost my kids
and it's just like over like
being a 15 year old who just wanted to
like fitting basically you know what I
mean
so
um
so um I started using
thank you
I started using heroin with him
he he's the one who like shot me up for
the first time
we dated
and then um
after that like my family didn't know
but after that it just became
like a wreck pretty quick like
19 years old I was a stripper
I was dating like a 50 year old sugar
daddy like
that was definitely like the epitome of
like a girl who had daddy issues
you know but um
I don't know like it's it's just been
rough like I came
I came to La like literally to pick up
drugs I was addicted to heroin and I was
getting heroin that was cut with
fentanyl and I wasn't aware of it like
and my dealer got arrested
and I was trying all these different
heroin and it wasn't getting me high
I was like what the heck and someone
told me oh it's cut with fentanyl I can
get some for you but it's in La so I
started driving out to LA to pick up
fentanyl well
end up being like why drive back I'll
just stay in my car out here and and and
pick up be able to be near the connect
so that ended me living out of my car
out here
slowly I lost my car
now homeless a sting and a tent and then
after that I was singing like an
abandoned house
um the cops came and got me out and now
I'm just like
living out of a suitcase just like
bouncing around with strangers
so
yeah
I'm 29 years old
I have two kids you know
and uh it's definitely like something
that like looking back it I wasn't like
it was it used to be so much fun you
know like to get high it used to be like
oh my God stupid feeling and now it's
just like there's been so much that's
happened it's almost just like
I'm just getting like obliterate uh
trying to get obliterated every day just
to forget
everything that's like resulted from
like you know what I mean it's like kind
of like ass backwards I never thought
there'd be like a day where like
I could say like I have friends that
have been shot murdered dad like like
when you start like dealing with people
that are like murderers like shooting
people stabbing people about meeting
people it's like you think like you're
rock bottom
is
you think you've hit your bottom I
thought I hit it when I lost my kids and
it's just like
you don't realize like sometimes like
how
far down Rock Bottom can really be
I used to see people lying on the
streets and I would touch them you know
I would be like who could do that like
who could just sleep on the street like
that they're so weird
and I get the point in my life where I'm
like I get that
like
I get like being so exhausted
and just like mentally tired
and having nothing
and just
you just don't care where you lie down
you're just like [ __ ] you know
and it's just like I never thought
growing up
I just never thought that this would be
my life you know
but
it feels like sometimes it's just too
much to go back
like
if I were to rejoin Society I wouldn't
even know
like what to do you know
I haven't worked in 10 years
like it just feels like sometimes it's
like what like I feel like I'm an alien
until like regain that like
it just feels like it's it's too
hard it's too like
like
overdosing and dying is like not even
like
doesn't seem like that bad anymore it
almost would be like a relief you know
just at least then you know like
[ __ ] you wouldn't have to just keep like
struggling you know
but
yeah I mean
it's not that crazy but
I don't know
what emotions do you go through it
sounds like the shame is what
yeah files on from your kids and from
everything else yeah and like when it
becomes intimidating to try to even get
out
yeah like I I've always cared a lot of
what people thought about me you know
like I can remember being little and my
dad telling me like
Sarah like
you know you've got to make sure you
marry Rich because all you have is your
looks like you you're not smart like so
you gotta gotta make sure you marry well
because
I'm like just hearing that as like a
little girl it's like
it's like
foot like I would never as an adult now
I would never say that to my child you
know what I mean like I would never make
them feel like
that all their worth and their value is
is like physical Beauty
and then when you're a Drug Act and
you're losing it I know that sounds vain
but it's kind of like you're like
[ __ ] like
like you know like when when people
start
recognizing you places and like like
when I've had people come up to me and
be like I can tell you're on the streets
and stuff and it's just like your ego is
like
damn like it's like that like
I can't even hide I can't even hide it
anymore like like I'm going places and
people are like can tell and it's just
like
you know there used to be like some
comfort in knowing that I could like
hide it and I could be like a covert
addict
you know and it's just like
I always had a clean record
and then when they took my kids away uh
my house got raided because my father my
child was on probation
and he was selling drugs and um
he um basically like
basically I I got charged for his drugs
and like he
at the end of it they brought him in
handcuffs
I didn't know he was with them like he
was in the cop car I guess he like led
me to LED them to our house he thought I
was cheating on him he was crazy he was
Psycho I honestly think he did it to get
back to me because he thought I was
cheating when I wasn't even cheating
um either way shouldn't have been with a
guy who is selling drugs and having
children you know what I mean but went
from a clean record to now I have
um felony
sales following sales over an ounce
selling child ninja went
and
those are not charges like I was always
so proud of like having a clean record
and then to go from that to that
and just sitting next to the person you
thought was like the the person you love
and is closest to you and they come in
handcuffs and they're looking at you
laughing and knowing that nothing
happened to them and it's all on you
like
like my brother has had situations
happen with his wife and he always took
the rap for her and I always thought
like oh like my my man would hold me
down and like
and it's not like that like when you do
drugs and you hang out with drug addicts
you're alone like you're you're always
alone
you know
I used to believe people and like that
people were gonna like save me or like
yeah I'll watch your stuff or we all and
now it's just like not even like a
question I'm just like no I'm good
because it's just like you you just kind
of like lose like your light and like
your hope and like Humanity because you
just are like constantly around just
people who
are smiling their face but with just so
much as like stabbing back would would
probably if you overdose they would be
picking your pockets
I I know some people who a guy overdosed
in
um their tent
my friend went by the tent uh there was
a dead body the tent that had been in
there for four days
top Pockets turned out no one called the
police
nothing
and they were telling my friend oh no
don't call the cop like just just really
found disgusting like
just sad just to know that that's like
someone's like brother or
someone's son and like
that he was basically like his like
desecrated and like just like
like I don't know that's just like so
like heartbreaking to know that you know
like and and just to know that like the
level of like that drugs can take you
that like there can be a living human
being and you are so selfish to care so
much about your own addiction
that a person can die and you won't even
move their dead body
or call the cops or get them help and
you would
take the shoes off their feet and
search their pockets
and then just walk around like
everything's good like that's the crazy
part
like it's just the stores out here are
crazy I have another friend who
um they think that the people that he
was living with he had an apartment
and you know there's scumbags out here
so having Apartments like a big deal
well they think because he wants his
apartment that they gave him like a hot
shot or something
not like they gave him something he
ended up having like a a stroke went
into a coma and all this
and they're living in his apartment and
all this shit's gone and
and they're talking about it like
like
oh yeah did you hear yeah they pulled
the blog on so and so and it's just like
wow like
like this man like gave you a place to
stay and like you're now like living
here without his consent and like
you're talking like he's dead like he's
gone
and you're talking about it like it's
like
oh yeah like like it's nothing like like
as long as you're high like that's all
that matters you know what I mean
it's it's disgusting it's really
disgusting
what is your drug now
um
God what is it I use hair I I use no no
sorry we kept talking about heroin
earlier
um I use fentanyl methamphetamines and
Xanax
like the fentanyls like my main drug I'm
addicted to and I also use the
methamphetamines because so the phenol
doesn't get me too down and then I have
so much anxiety
that like I use a Xanax too it's like it
comes to the point where it's like I
feel like I've had to add so much stuff
in just to make me be able to like
walk around and function that it's like
it's like
pretty much just like
self-medicating I have a broken arm
right now broken wrist I've had it for
two months I didn't know it was broken
my ex did it to me and
um he said you're being a baby it's it's
probably just spraying you know
stop like and then and I just went to
the hospital
um like a week ago or something else I
had an abscess and
they told me they're like your wrist is
broken like it's we need to re-break
your wrist put pins in it like we need
to get your referral for orthopedic
surgeon and to know like for two months
I've been walking around with a [ __ ]
broken wrist
and all because what like
like my boyfriend my ex-boyfriend said
like
you know like I don't know all because
like the people around you just
I don't know it's it's just a trip
it's like when it starts affecting your
health like
I went in there with a broken wrist
two abscesses and then
um a concussion from like I had
and like the nurses were just telling me
they're like
dude like what are you like your health
like
like what are you doing and I was just
like
I don't know it's I hate I'm afraid of
hospitals and I think it has to do with
being an addict you're afraid of like
Authority cops and I think sometimes
hospitals get kind of like shoot in with
that
you know and so
and you just don't want to deal with it
it's just like oh well I gotta get my
fix like I don't have time to do it or I
need to be high enough to go do it or
whatever you know
but yeah so I gotta handle that
situation
what are you afraid of now
honestly
I'm afraid of
my sons
growing up
and
thinking that
I didn't love them
and then I didn't want want them and to
become like me I don't want them to ever
use drugs or
like
I don't ever want them
to have to like
go the places that I have gone you know
what I mean
I just want them to like do well and
succeed and be happy and like
I know they're they don't understand why
I'm not around you know
it's like mommy's mommy's sick you know
but you can only
really get away with that for so long
it's been a year now since I've seen
my oldest it's been two years since I've
seen my youngest
my youngest was taken away when he was
um
three I know he won he was two
and my oldest is with his dad and he's
um
six
and
I was a good mom
I was a really good mom
you know
I was wanting to have kids
and I was a really good mom
and it just really sucks because it's
like
he
they know like they're gonna grow up
with that you know
I hate that my
I hate that like I've
gifted them
in a sense at least am I
pain like I've not gifted them because
it's terrible but you know we inherit
our
we inherit our parents
um
there
issues and things and
it's just so terrible to know like that
like
I'm basically like giving my son's the
pain of like
an absentee mother and thinking that
like their moms
chose dope over them
and from the outside looking in it's
like
I love my sons
I love myself
and I it's so hard because everyone
thinks it's like you choose drugs over
them but it's like it's just not so
simple it's it's like people don't get
like how hard it is you know
have you tried to quit
you're going to rehab seven times
uh when I was trying to get my son back
well I went to
I detox once when I was like younger
and then
um
another detox
like a few years after that and then
when I lost my kids I was like I'm gonna
get my kids back and I just like
I would go in and I would just like
freak out and and leave like I would
start doing well
it was like I would start doing well and
I would like to sabotage myself like I
would self-sabotage it was just like
all I know now is like
this [ __ ] pain like
to be like feel good and happy and to
love myself and to like be healthy and
like to be in healthy relationships is
like
it's almost like scary like you know
what I mean it's like you're not used to
that you know what I mean
but
I don't know I I still want to get sober
I still I still think I still have my
pipe dream of like oh I am gonna get
sober
you know one day I mean I guess I don't
really say that that much anymore
[Music]
it's been all that difficult to
not relapse on
it is honestly like I can handle the
detox like I can handle like the
physical detox if it's painful but like
I know I can make it through I've made
it through it in jail you know like
it's just still like compounding of like
when you're coming off the drugs and
then like
all the shame and things you've um
other things you've done while you were
like loaded and things that you never
would have done if you weren't and and
all the people you hurt and and it just
all comes like flooding in You When
You're Sober it's like just almost like
too much it's like overwhelming it's
like
like I I it's like I've repressed it for
a reason you know
but
you know it's like you have to deal with
those things eventually
and say what other choices there I know
it sounds cheesy but it's just like
I wish I would have like
stayed in like a program and like
listened when they said like all that
addicts all at least two is when
addiction is jail or death and it's
really true like
I've never had so many friends and
people I know die like within the past
like year
some of them aren't even fentanyl
addicts there's a lot of friends I know
too that have there might be like
addicted to meth and they got meth
laceless fentanyl or
you know
and so it's just like
other people stab Rob
shot like
like I'm a white girl from Orange County
like if you were to ask me 10 years ago
if I would have been having exchanges
with gang members and
having people I know that are like shot
and stabbed and all this stuff I would
have like laughed in your face like I I
was
where are you staying now
I'm on the streets now I
just
wherever the wind takes me
how do you make money
um
honestly
like I still I like I go and I steal
some stores I boost but really just like
if I'm missing
I feel like sometimes like my grandma
used to say like I'll make a good lawyer
because it's just like
I don't know I just feel like I've look
sometimes I just like
I've had to like lower myself and do
things that I just
wouldn't like wouldn't do
like
things I never would have done or people
I would have never hung out with
before
you know using I was stripping before to
pay for my addiction you know
and like
I always said I would never escort
I and I ended up trying it two times
and I was like I'm never gonna do it
again
and I haven't like I've been lucky with
that but
even just like
stripping I mean that takes away like
I was raised Catholic you know I was
like came from a good family like
it's like I feel like when I would like
like I have to get [ __ ] up in order to
like
do it you know what I mean like and I
feel like I have to every day the people
that I'm like trying to get Dope From or
something
I'm having to like
you're having to play a role like
like oh this guy he wants this Blood he
wants this little toy so I'm I'm gonna
play that role to get what I need to get
and eventually it's like you've played
so many roles like
you kind of lose like who you are
you know
it's just anything
you'll do like anything to just get the
drug
whatever that means you know
sir what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um
important lesson
I don't know I guess
just
I wish I would
have not cared so much about others you
know we should have
not been in such a rush to grow up
I wish it would have not
like
look to men or physical items to
fill a void or hole in itself you know
what I mean
just learn how to be happy
just being you know what I mean
um
and just
I don't know I just wish I would I would
have
I wish I would have just not been in a
rush to grow up I wish I would have just
been innocent a little girl and
running around just
getting my knees dirty in my little
sundress
you know like not like
I feel like when you're a teenage girl
it's like everything's so dramatic and
you want to be
you want to be this adult and like you
know your hormones and you're starting
to like boys and this and that and it's
just like
it can all be innocent fun and people
there are people that can just party in
high school and it's over it's over with
but
if you're hanging out with people that
are doing like
hard drugs you're probably shouldn't be
there like you know what I mean
you know I feel like growing up it's
okay to go to like a cake party and you
know whatever but
if there's someone around you that's
like doing like heroin or like these
hard drugs there's there's something
wrong and if there's an older person
with an underage person like that's
there's something not right there
you know
I just never really understood that like
being younger
I'm like what's the problem if I'm 15
and he's 22 like
my poor father
I was 19 I brought a 50 year old
um
boyfriend home I was going to I guess a
like beginning life crisis
but now he's getting me back he's like
dating guys that are probably like the
same age as me or younger so
my dad's living his best life actually
because like he's he's not like he's his
HIV is like doing good and he's now that
he's like come out of the closet he's
um
he moved to Palm Springs and he's like
he's like happy now
but I I haven't spoken to anyone in my
family and
um a long time
actually got stopped recently by a cop
because I I didn't know this but they
had put out
I'm missing person
report for me
so
that was like kind of sad you know but I
just don't want to like stress them out
with
I'd rather than like
it's not I have to know
you know what I mean
because
I just don't like kill my family
just to know like
just the things that I'm dealing with
like on a daily basis like
and I know that like
my grandma like I love my grandma like
she basically like
raised me and I know like she could take
away the pain and change it she would
but she can't you know
um
my grandma she after when I was 15 after
that whole thing happened living with my
friend and all that with like the heroin
my dad ended up
selling the house and
calling us on a Sunday and saying I'm
moving on Thursday with or without you
guys
turned out he had been embezzling money
and was on the Run we didn't know that
then
but you just left he just left us so I
was like couch surfing and my grandma
came
and she found us and
um we went to go live with them and to
this day like my grandma is like
I consider her like my um
she's I consider her like my parent like
you know what I mean
and
she's the only one that I really kind of
keep in contact with
but again it's just lies I'm lying to
her about
everything and I and I hate saying that
because I love her you shouldn't lie to
people you love but
uh she's also in her 80s and I don't
want to kill someone I love with stress
of being you know what I mean
of being like I'm doing this I'm doing
that so I'd rather her just like
like be happy and like stress-free and
like
think I'm like doing good and like you
know
that's pretty much it
Sarah thank you so much for sharing your
story yeah
I wish you lots of luck getting getting
out of here getting back with the kids
thank you thank you
thank you very much